let's talk about some of the real
interesting benefits from the Sun that
go beyond just vitamin D so as you know
when the Sun hits your skin there's
certain chemical reactions that occur
that generate vitamin D from cholesterol
in your skin so people are always
against cholesterol but you need
cholesterol to actually make vitamin D
okay so there's a lot of benefits to
cholesterol but check this out
when the Sun hits your skin and the
retina okay through your eye you get a
chemical conversion of increasing
serotonin and serotonin can greatly
affect your mood this is why of course
when you're in the Sun you feel much
better and when the winter comes and
it's dark you don't feel that great if
it goes on and on
in fact when I originally graduated from
college I wanted to go and live in
Washington State okay it was just
beautiful there and I just loved the
whole scenery and and how green the
grass was well little did I know the
reason why it's so green is it rained so
much in fact for six months I don't
think the Sun came out at all and I got
really depressed so I moved from
Washington State down to California
actually right next to the Mojave Desert
to dry out all the Sun and my mood
definitely went up so there is a
relationship between the Sun and your
mood via certain hormones okay number
two it effects melatonin actually
reduces melatonin melatonin is the
hormone that helps you sleep
so darkness stimulates melatonin but
light Sun will decrease this this makes
you sleepy so the Sun wakes you up okay
so another benefit number three the heat
from the Sun and the humidity that's
generated from the Sun and also the
environment has the power to decrease
viral loads even from Co vat19 and this
is where you're going to see as you go
into the summer you're going to find
that a lot of people are going to do
much much better simply because the
reproduction of that virus is affected
by the temperature and the humidity
of the environment and this is why these
viruses a lot of times are seasonal like
influenza comes out in the winter but
kind of goes away in the summer now
number four UV this is a wavelength that
you're getting from the Sun that has
antibacterial effects and this has
nothing to do with vitamin d UV inhibits
the growth of certain bacteria and other
microbes even through glass it can
actually inhibit tetanus typhoid TB
staph strep and many other
microorganisms are number five the Sun
will increase resistance to infection so
it helps your immune system alright
number six the infrared wavelength of
the Sun is great for wound healing and
decreasing pain there's many different
types of therapy using infrared and if
you haven't seen the benefits of vitamin
D from the Sun you got to check that out
I put it right here